on fait les pompes ouais la pompe à 100
euros donc tu continues tu penses en
euros à chaque fois sa force et ses
danses à l'ultime à chaque fois de la
tête froide et à inventer au moins sont
battus qui ce qu'il veut sans pompe à 30
des morts et l'arabe à 34 ans deux fois
sans ça fait 3000
bah oui ça va tu es blindés c'est pour
une à ce soir comme on l'a dit on
t'appelle gras dur et c'est très
important pour toi ton association
moncaut ce soir on va jouer à pousser
c'est gagner du temps entretien et tu
vas jouer avec matthieu delormeau
c'est très simple il va y avoir ici il
va y avoir un ici un bon ils peuvent de
développé couché qui va être installé ou
la tour à tour souleva poids si vous y
arrivez tous les deux on notera ce poids
de 10 kg voilà le premier qui n'arrivent
pas à soulever la barre on l'a fait
redescendre à la faire descendre et
lamont terme de lots remontée a perdu si
vous propose de jouer pour la bonne
cause chaque développé-couché rapportera
500 euros pour l'association vaduz en
mer un d'accord j'allais devoir faire un
petit échauffement rapide avec une barre
assez légères à 50 kg je vais demander à
matthieu delormeau et gras dur d'aller
sur scène c'est le forcer
[Applaudissements]
alors ras dur face à matthieu delormeau
non j'ai pas fait ça moi alors je vous
le dis on va jouer pour 500 euros à
chaque fois donc là on a et on a 50 kg
l'a alors là il n'y a pas 50 kg et 20 et
l'appareil va la barre des 10 ah oui je
crois qu'il atterrissait tour de main et
tout ça c'est facile ça coco ça va c'est
quand qu'il a fait ce qu'il veut
démarrer
on va démarrer avec traduire une radio
vas-y raconte kg s'est pas à chaque fois
que les deux lèveront là bas il y aura
sa sous louer le bien qu'ils attention
ça va c'est tranquille au cul voilà un
matthieu delormeau 50 kg on y va ils ont
échoué tu vois exhortant 40 easy police
un coach étranger au monde
on monte à 60 ans il ya déjà cinq barils
60 km 500 encore ça c'est encore salon
la sauce pour l'installer mathieu et la
thielle c'est pour l'association
gradueront rappelle 60 mère si c'est bon
pour l'association en tranches et gay du
combo qui au gras durs qui fait un
travail exceptionnel pour cette
association attention 60 kg samoans
baziémo gras durs sa venue la différence
je fais ça c'est bon 60 kg c'est google
qui vont arriver matthieu delormeau et
gras dur mathieu et prémont chérie tu
veux faire tout de suite et 70 70 quant
au temps derrière matthieu delormeau
spray pas on se retrouve dans un instant
les cherry pour la fille de tout propos
très durs
pour l'instant je vous le dis on joue
avec matthieu delormeau matthieu
delormeau qui a deux passions dans la
vie
la musculation et vend mecs vous
malheureusement va plus à la salle de
sports pour l'instant il ya mille euros
puisqu'à chaque fois que vous arrivez à
lever la barre tous les deux à faire une
traction on rajoute 500 euros pour
l'association
on est à une barre à 70 kg vous avez
déjà peu lever une barre à 70 c'est bon
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
vas-y mode radio élèves le disque à 81
kg battue verte au ski et les shabaks et
de ses amis ont fait douce un ami du co
2 4 je suis pas d'accord c'est beau
l'amitié
[Musique]
ok
on est à 1500 euros pour l'instant pour
l'association va faire 80 kg et après on
fera la pompe à 100 euros
vous avez déjà fait des pompes à 100
euros une très bonne y attention
mathieu n'a t'on pas 100 euros c'est
parti mon chéri à 80 qui va là ça va
passer encore deux jours est plus par la
non lé ton énergie laquelle pas là ça va
c'est bon ça passe ça passe ça passe
mais c'est déjà un truc à vous dit en
fait cette traction
si la russie elle va la grappe à 500
euros mais mille car il ya 90 et non pas
80 90 3 je vais faire un coup comme ça
ouais ouais la tête la tête des 40 +6
attention graduera 90 pour 1000 euros
pour l'association enfants chez vous et
du congo près tu m'écoutes savage pas tu
peux regarder d'ici
alors laquelle tu as toi tu vois ce que
je propose qu'on est à 2500 euros gras
dur on a une idée ouais c'est quoi ton
idée mathieu c'était quoi il sait si la
sils maria ont fait les pompes
ouais la pompe à 100 euros donc tu
continues tu prends soin euros à chaque
fois sa force a laissé dans sa lutte
team à chaque fois de la tête froide et
à un rebond dans ce roman sont battus
qui ce qu'il veut sans pompe à 30 des
morts et l'arabe à 34 ans deux fois sans
ça fait 3000
bah oui ça va tu es blindés c'est pour
une essence
[Rires]
mettez-vous là j'en passe pas trop fait
tu es tu peux aller on y va à temps mais
non les caméras sont là ce serait bien
que tu te mettes comme sa forme l'agent
danny richer oui voilà c'est papa à
tanga d'urfé garçons d'attention mouche
attention c'est parti on y va c'est
parti allez on y va à deux cas ça y est
c'est fait
oui alors c'est plus facile les jambes
écartées que comme ça et je t'emmerde en
2 23 24 balzac barry 27 28 29
cros [ __ ] d'affaires de 33 5 à 6 37 38
bon match automnal mois
ah bon
[Applaudissements]
c'était pour l'association je pouvais
pas m'arrêter là ça ira bien mais tu en
as fait combien l'europe est de 560 60
que je divise par cros et moi 40 avait
100 non non non c'est on avait fait un
jeu il fallait que vous fassiez les deux
mains ça s'additionne pas non mano à
mano banamba norman ans donc ça fait
soixante fois voix soit 161 10 ça fait
ça fait 60 x 17 pour la sauce je vous le
dis on va donner donc voilà on va faire
le calcul y avait combien 2500 et ben je
veux dire on va donner 8500 euros
[Musique]